switch
[Music]
well it's already time to start thinking
about full season as wind nightlife is
set to host auditions next week for
their world renowned venues here to
share more about the process we have the
GM of XS Nightclub Alvin young here with
us today Alvin thank you so much for
being here thank you so much for having
us it's crazy it's the month of January
but we're already thinking about the
pools tell us a little bit about the
audition process and what venues are
hiring absolutely well again thank you
for having us here when my life is
hosting auditions next week Wednesday
January 11th and Thursday January 12th
inside the Vandal ballrooms at the Wynn
we're looking to hire into our amazing
portfolio of Brands which include excess
nightclub Encore Beach Club Encore Beach
Club at night wind Field Club at
Allegiant stadium and cost Supply wow so
the big one the big ones if you're
coming out for these auditions there's a
lot on the line and I have multiple
friends that have gone through the
process and I know it's not the easiest
but it's all also not as intimidating as
everyone thinks so run us through how
should people prepare if they want to
come out for the auditions well you have
to have a lot of energy first and
foremost energy is going to be the
premier thing that we look for in such a
short type of audition other than that
being able to articulate exactly what
your experience is and things like that
that's probably going to be the best way
to do it well right as you said everyone
how much fun it is at
how cool for the people that do get
hired they get to work alongside some of
the biggest names biggest CJs in the
world is that really what draws people
in yeah absolutely we have the top tier
talent that we have at when nightlife we
have the likes of Swedish House Mafia
chain smokers we have David Guetta
marshmallow Diplo and many others
working for us is the best of the best
yeah the list just goes on and on it has
to just be so much fun and I know it's
like a tight-knit family over there and
on top of servers cocktail servers
there's a few other roles you guys are
looking for as well right absolutely
marketing model positions is what
candidates are going to be seeking
lifeguards security officers are also
included but bar apprentices and server
assistance nonetheless and you guys make
the process fun you guys have like
selfie moments and music so when you
walk in it's kind of a fun party element
right or atmosphere correct we Elevate
the experience we don't particularly
want just a formal interview we Elevate
the brand by adding DJ music and photo
moments photo booths and then it's
essentially what it is a memory and if
people want to audition do they just
show up should they apply for something
online what's that process like when
nightlife.com is the Premier site to be
able to go to and apply okay go there
apply and then auditions are next week
and it's going to be so much fun a lot
on the line I think this summer season
is going to be bigger and better than
ever it will be absolutely Alvin thank
you so much for being here because it's
a really cool experience all the
information on your screen if you want
to take part in the auditions again they
are happening Wednesday January 11th and
Thursday January 12th inside the Vandal
Ballroom